[Music]
welcome everybody well the whole team is
right here after an Oscar night to
remember
look no host no problem there were
record set in shocking moments that I
don't think anybody saw coming like
Robin Allen didn't see the edge of that
stage right off the stage and we're
going to show you what happened and oh
my goodness gracious what is going on
with Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
what is going on let me do what said
social media right off the deep end
are you ready for this performance oh oh
yes we are ready and so excited
Bradley's not that nervous about tonight
everybody's saying oh yeah yeah it's
chill it I've heard you've been calm
cool and collected as that's what the
producers word out there where did you
directed this thing so if it fails it's
on me that's true I have no one to blame
[Music]
[Applause]
I just want to make sure we give people
what they want you know what fans really
seem to walk last night was for Bradley
and Gaga's stars born romance to be real
during the nearly 4 minute performance
Bradley and Gaga's eyes stayed intensely
locked and Twitter pretty much broke the
moment they saying side-by-side
one person actually tweeted quote and
with those opening notes Lady Gaga is
now expecting Bradley Cooper's child I
was like are they doing it thank you for
believing in us that chemistry was like
I think they've become really dear
friends you can feel it and it's like
then there was the way he has courted
her on stage Gaga and Bradley held hands
over his girlfriend Irina Shayk slap
fans pointed out she sat supporting leap
between them the entire night she also
left to her feet during their standing
ovation and on the carpet Bradley told
us a star is born has special meaning
for their one and a half year old
daughter first what we ended the movie
below her room so she was in the native
with noise for the first six months of
our lives
yeah or so like never want to hear that
sound drag with the rest of your life
there was a huge night for gaga minutes
after the performance she won her first
Oscar for Best Original Song and got
delivered an emotional thank you to the
leading man Bradley there is not a
single person on the planet that could
have sang this song with me but you how
you feeling mama what does it mean to
you to know that for the rest of your
life
Oscar winner goes in front of your name
and the Oscar goes to brown email
[Applause]
rami malek also had the best night ever
when his name was announced in the Best
Actor category
he gave co-star turned girlfriend Lucy
wasn't quite the kiss you're the heart
of this film you have captured my heart
thank you so much even on our easy
platform Romney want to shine a
spotlight on his love you're a huge
winner because you also walked away with
a relationship huh but here's what the
TV audience at home didn't see happen
urami during the show the Bohemian
Rhapsody star fell off the stage and
into the audience
paramedics briefly treated him but by
the time he hit the Governor's Ball
Romney told us he was ready to party I
don't like to pull the Freddy moves out
much but if there's ever a night
and that's what happens when you win
enough from rummy to Spike Lee who
stirred up major Oscar drama what goes
up put those up what what he got a
classic here tonight
spike rocks emoji bling from dude the
right thing thirty years after that
movie failed to win Best Screenplay
last night spike won his very first
Oscar for writing black Klansmen listen
the moment of the night when you gave a
bear hug like I've never seen before I
jumped in his Sam Jackson's arms I had
hops but after spike lost Best Director
to Roma's Alfonso Cuaron and Best
Picture to Green Book people inside the
ceremony say spike was furious and
turned his back to the stage as Green
books producers accepted their award can
you give us your thoughts on that Best
Picture win let me take another sip
next question no I thought was courtside
at the Garden the ref made a bad call
whoa despite the disk Green Book was a
big winner taking home three Oscars
including Best Supporting Actor for
Maher Sheela Ali who portrayed pianist
dr. Donald Shirley I've just honored to
be a part of that story
and it was a record-breaking night for
women at the Oscars with 15 total wins
Olivia called maybe including Best
Actress winner Olivia Colman the
favorite star beat Glenn Close who swept
the category at every other major award
show close you've been my idol cos so
long and this is not how I wanted it to
be and I think you're amazing
let me very much I'm feeling really
really good darling of this award season
I was upset about all the people who've
been that I was gonna Regina Regina King
won for Best Supporting Actress for her
role in if Beals we could talk Chris
Evans had this superhero moment
escorting her to the Oscar stage they
reunited at Vanity Fair's Oscar party
where Regina was feeling the love you
know what I don't feel like I just have
the universe looking over me everyone
was rooting for you yeah and I felt it
also at Vanity Fair Jennifer Hudson
fangirling all night with everyone from
Kats co-star ADRA's Elbe to Barbra
Streisand and Katz J hud sings the song
Barbra cover I just build memories I'm
coming straight from that
everything is done live on the set it's
a lot of hard work we created it as we
go how did it go I think I got away
another film we're excited about new
behaved talked about another Austin
Powers trope there are it's likely to be
from dr. Evil's point of view no one can
stop me from dr. evil to Aquaman
Jason talking about the Girl Scouts
selling memo is instead of Samoas I want
the shortbread Andy I'll put that in the
freezer you don't want your own cookies
I want to know what kind of snack she
brought us all tonight guys there's a
rotisserie going on back there chicken
on awkwafina's mine when she answered
one of our questions based on the
nominated bill what's the one vice you
want to eliminate this year I need a lot
of Costco chicken and I think that I
should take a break
she's not kidding listen to her SAG
Awards must have a Costco chicken is it
weird when you walk in Costco to buy the
chicken do people stop you no thanks
sweatin my eyes are dilated and I got
one goal get to that chicken
[Music]